my name is dustin yachts this is design
systems
aren't hard so you might be asking
yourself what exactly is a design system
i first saw this graphic from nate
baldwin in a talk at artifact conference
fall of 2019 it really drove home just
how many different definitions
there are to the term design system just
how complicated it can be
each of those circles is an artifact and
a team
made that artifact whether it's you know
the ui kit
um the component library the
documentation
a lot of people don't think about
content strategy as part of a design
system but it definitely is
and if you kind of squint your eyes and
look at this
just right it kind of starts to resemble
i don't know like an org chart
conway's law states organizations which
design
systems are constrained to produce
designs which are copies of the
communication structures
of these organizations it's kind of a
long-winded way of saying that products
tend to resemble the communication of
the teams
that build those products
uncle dave rupert has his own law your
website is a manifestation
of your organization's problems
products tend to reflect the
communication problems of the teams
building that product
if you take a look at this graphic one
more time we can see that each of these
artifacts is coming
from a different team either
communicating or not communicating with
other teams
something like documentation maybe it's
owned by a product team or maybe it's
owned by a technical writers
the ui presentation layer could be owned
by a ux department
while the actual ui kit and the visual
design language is owned by maybe a
brand team
or a marketing team teams that you know
don't necessarily work together
on a day-to-day basis and that doesn't
really
you know clear things up when you're
trying to think about what a design
system is
so let's think about it from a different
angle what isn't
a design system
a sigma library that's not a design
system you know a figma library or a ui
kit built with some other tool
it could have all of your components in
it it could have all of your colors all
of your buttons
uh you can show people how your your
menus look
um you know this is going to represent
maybe one team's idea
of the design system really well but it
may not be perfectly suited to another
team
you know developers they like figma it's
a lot nicer
than using some other software at times
for a developer to get in and
get the data that they need to make the
product that they need
but it doesn't tell them you know it
often doesn't tell them things like
how things look when they animate or
what they look like when a page
transitions
so okay maybe a figma library that's not
a design system
uh what else what else is in a design
system a react component library
this is the kind of thing that
developers always want when they're
talking about
a design system they want something that
lets them
do the least amount of work when it
comes to building new product new
interface
a react component library is a great way
to share code easily
helps you build functional prototypes or
even entire products really quickly
with a minimum of custom code but this
still isn't a design system it doesn't
always say
it doesn't always reflect the flow of a
customer through the product
very well it'll show you know what a
button looks like or what a form looks
like
but it can't actually show you what it
looks like to go from beginning to end
for a customer
so what else an external website
promoting your design system
uh you know i think we all love to check
out the latest design systems that are
being released by some of the big
companies out there the
you know the googles the githubs all
kinds of
really great things to look at things to
learn from
lightning's been doing really great work
with web components
polaris is amazing for theming
but these are actually not design
systems either these
these are just kind of a snapshot frozen
in time
of the system that that company is
actually using internally
a lot of times these public versions
that they release
they can lag by months or even years
behind what is actually being used
inside of the company
these are all the artifacts these are
not the system
so what is a design system
at the root it's an agreement on how
digital products are made
that's all it's an agreement within your
team
or your department or your company
on what your products are what they look
like
and how they work what kind of
agreements are we talking about
we're talking about user interface
design how the digital experience
looks interaction design how it feels
you know when you're actually clicking
around when you're going through and
using the software
content strategy again this isn't always
super obvious but this is a huge part of
a design system
we need to know how our digital
experience should sound
to the customer when they're when
they're reading our interface
and near and dear to my heart
documentation
we need to know how this digital
experience is crafted
whether we're designers or developers uh
whether
we're in marketing it doesn't matter we
need to know the decisions that have
been made
and why they've been made and that's
documentation
design systems unfortunately they take
time
they take time because it takes time to
reach an agreement
on big things on small things
you might be surprised to learn just how
long it can take to agree
about something as simple as a button
you know just
your standard primary button can be
weeks or months
of back and forth and negotiation uh
maybe you're testing
your ideas and your assumptions in your
live product using a b
testing this is going to take time
here are the primary buttons from five
different design systems they're all
very similar they're all buttons
they all have text uh you can click them
and they do a thing
but they'll have very distinct
differences whether it's color or shape
shadow sometimes a design system will
have
let you put icons on a button sometimes
it won't
on the internet the button is one of
your primary interaction points with a
customer
and that means that a lot of people have
a lot of opinions about it
inside of your company and it's going to
be a large source of frustration
when you start building a design system
so you need to be prepared for that
so we know they take time but you know
time is money and that means that design
systems take money you can't shortchange
this you you should take the time
to do it right um
so why bother i mean this seems like
it seems like an awful lot we've gotta
you know we gotta think about
oh we have the you know agree on buttons
we have to agree on typography
we agree on the tools that we're going
to use
so what are we getting out of this
the answer to borrow a business word is
scale
design systems are all about it um
you're going to get
interface design at scale interaction
building at scale
content creation at scale
when everyone on your team knows how a
thing should be built
they can just go build it they don't
have to to stop and think they don't
have to ask questions
they just know
in my current job i'm working on design
systems
and we do a lot of support more support
than you might think
and the absolute number one question we
get
how do i do x how do i
use a primary button how do i use a
secondary button
in relation to a primary button how do i
invoke a modal
and the number two question why
this is you know as important if not
more important than the first one
to give people the ability to do things
on their own they need to know not only
what they should do
but they also need to know why they
should do it so that the next time
they encounter a problem they can apply
that rationale
and come up with their own answer and
not have to come to you
i believe the design system is a service
not a product and this it can be
difficult inside of companies
to convince people of this they want to
treat it like a product
they want to do road maps as if it was a
product
but at the end of the day it's not it's
a service
uh it is providing answers it is
deciding on new answers to new questions
it's you know helping people integrate
the design system with a new product or
an existing product
you know legacy code bases that power
large chunks of corporate websites
are very hard to get design systems
working sometimes
and that is the job you know treating
like a service
um you know having support channels
having dedicated people in those support
channels people who aren't
writing code that day all they're doing
is there to ask questions
answer questions
because really you need to answer
questions not write code
coming back to this picture uh you know
again there's a lot of
artifacts here um
what do you think is the most important
one what would you guess
you know i think if you come from a
design background you're going to
kind of tend towards the ones that are
kind of reddish pink the ui presentation
layer or the components or the ui kit
if you're a product person you're going
to be very drawn to the purple you're
going to want to talk a lot about
processes
if you come from a brand background
where you're thinking about like
the holistic look and feel of a company
content strategy is going to stick out
as well as the visual design language
if you're a ui person you know maybe a
little bit of everything
and if you're a developer i mean dev
standards that's a big one
so which one is the biggest the most
important
if you only had the time or the money
to do one thing and do it well
what should it be
i would say documentation i think
documentation is the
single most important piece of the
puzzle
a design system we've already talked
about is made up of agreements
you need to write those agreements down
you can't just say oh well
you know two months ago in a meeting on
tuesday
somebody said this so let's do that
you need to have it written down where
everybody can see it and review
it and understand it and edit it as they
need
that is the most important thing you can
do
if you have the budget i would strongly
recommend
you hire a service designer this may not
be a job pal you've heard of before
i hadn't before i started my current job
a service designer is there to think
about people and think about
infrastructure
you can think of them as the
personification of documentation and
customer support
they may often come from a ui background
or development background
but they are there to think from you
know a to z
about the customer uh they can help
drive adoption of new design systems if
you know you have a deadline you need to
have a design system rolled out by a
certain date
they are absolutely invaluable they are
the extroverts to the to the development
and design introverts they will make the
relationships
uh they will you know find the data
convince the stakeholders that need to
be convinced
uh they are fantastic
and finally your documentation should
change
as often as necessary you shouldn't
think of it as
set in stone you know
we're not writing things in spiral
notebooks but you should think about
what kind of software that you use
when you're writing down your
documentation it should be something
that's easy to edit
quick to edit that everybody has access
to
i would recommend not using a git
repository i think that's a common
pitfall for teams you know developers
they love get repositories they love
markdown
but that's not the friendliest for
designers or product
designers love things like figma they
love to write things down in there
that's not the friendliest for a
developer
so think you know think about something
uh kind of abstracted something agnostic
i've seen people uh use things like
notion really well
um you can you know obviously use
something like google docs
it's got a lot of great tools um one of
the nice things about something like
google docs is
it lets you know who changed something
and when it changed
which can be super important down the
road
at the end of the day design systems can
be used to help everyone
that's a great thing when i say everyone
i don't just mean designers and
developers but
specifically the users
users that aren't always thought about
design systems give you accessibility at
scale
they give you a system that you can be
reasonably assured
a button is going to work as a button
links are going to work as links
animations are going to automatically
respect
the prefers reduced motion
directive without having to think about
it without having to write extra code
somebody can simply pull in an animated
component
and know that it's going to work in an
accessible manner
it also gives you inclusion at scale
you can be sure that when you pull in a
form field it's going to accept accented
characters
it's going to accept various types of
unicode like
somebody wants to put an emoji in a
field it'll probably work if you've made
one form field work that way they should
all work that way
things like right to left text
presentation is just going to work
this is an incredibly difficult thing to
do on just about every product i've ever
worked on
but once you do it once and you do it
right it's really easy
to use that across all of the different
places where you're displaying text
in our in our products that indeed we
actually have we are global company we
have lots of job postings
that are mixed languages and this is a
very complicated
thing to fix but once you fix it once
it's
it's fixed uh somebody wants to write a
job title in japanese
and a job description in english easy
if somebody wants to write a job title
in
german and a job description in
arabic it's done it's great
so always think about you know how you
can take those hard problems
that need to be solved and figure out a
way to solve them once for everybody
drive that that scale of inclusion that
scale of accessibility
so if you learn nothing else from this
talk
learn this if you do nothing else
write documentation if you can do
nothing else
plus one thing hire a service designer
design systems are hard
and that's the work and that's okay
um there's you know in our industry it's
it's really
it's really tempting to try and make
things easy for ourselves
as designers and as developers at the
expense
of ease of use for an end user and we
need to avoid that trap
we need to do the hard work we need to
find
the unified methods of working for our
teams
so that you can reap the rewards long
term
uh superior experience is not just for
your developers and your designers
but also your end users
just want to drop some resource links
here at the end some of the places where
i found some of the information in this
hopefully you've learned something
hopefully you can take something back
and
make your team a little bit better
thank you very much have a good day